hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast turnkey resources the genetics
toolkit I am jus do rock of leopards and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational virtual meeting presented by
labyrinth for more information please
visit lab routes comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this session is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left this is an
educational virtual meeting and thus
offers free continuing education credits
after the session is over please click
on the CD button located in the bottom
left hand corner of your web page and
follow the process of obtaining your
credits I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Jean F Jenkins PhD and
RN clinical advisor for the division of
policy communications and education at
the National Human Genome Research
Institute which is NHGRI the NIH dr. Bob
Wilden MD chief of the genomic
healthcare branch at the NIH NHGRI
helped create the genetics toolkit but
is not able to join us today dr. Jenkins
previously worked at the NIH Clinical
Center nursing department the National
Cancer Institute and the genomic
healthcare branch of NHGRI dr. Jenkins
has been motivated and committed to
preparing others to become aware of plan
for and integrate genetic concepts into
clinical practice dr. Wilden as an a BMG
certified clinical geneticist
has practiced general clinical genetics
in academic and non-academic settings
including in rural healthcare systems he
served as medical faculty at three
academic centers performing grant funded
research on rare genetic disorders
caring for patients and teaching dr.
Jenkins and wilden's complete bios are
found on the lab roots website I will
now turn it over to dr. Jenkins for her
presentation good afternoon welcome to
the last session of today I'm hearing a
lot of echoes so hopefully I just fixed
that the last session today is called
turnkey resources the genetics toolkit
so don can you let me know if you can
hear me okay now excellent so let's go
to the first question of my presentation
that I'd like to have you contribute
your answers to why did you decide to
attend today's session to learn more
about genetics in the clinic and dawn
will send out the information to you to
be able to respond is it because it's
the current craze to make a difference
in offering personalized healthcare
because your patients are asking you
questions that you can't answer because
you like a challenge or to be able to be
positioned to the lead the way I'm just
curious about the audience so if you can
respond to one of the
we'll see what the makeup of the group
is
so it looks like we have a lot of
leaders in the group because many of you
said that you'd like to be able to be
positioned to lead the way and this is
fantastic because I think a lot of the
resources that will discuss this
afternoon can get you started on that
pathway if you're not already familiar
with some of these resources the other
valuable side effect of learning all
this information is that we can make a
tremendous difference in offering
personalized health care so it's very
exciting to see that that's also one of
the benefits that you think you will
achieve with today's session so let's go
to the next slide and I'll just explain
to you um if I can get out of the pool
there we go that indeed I agree with you
that the discoveries of genomic
variation associated with health disease
and treatment options when translated
into practice can make a tremendous
difference for a patient and his or her
family along with that comes the benefit
of personalized care we had this
specific information that may benefit
that individual and perhaps his or her
family and I'm sure many of you have
been getting questions ask my patients
because they are interested in the
potential for benefit but they may have
also heard about potentially safer
options such as it in choosing the best
drug or the best dose for a treatment
intervention so why you I'm so excited
to see that primary care providers are
taking such a great interest in this
topic because physicians nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
are often the first contact of
individuals entering the healthcare
system you may also have ongoing
relationships with them and their
families and so your position to make a
huge difference to that individual as
well as many other individuals in their
family so I really do believe and
slightly biased that this toolkit is for
you
so I want to review a little bit about
the toolkit first off as you may
recognize it is only a beginning this is
more of a lifelong learning journey
because so much information changes on a
daily basis so you may need to focus in
on where this information can make the
most difference for your patience you
may have other team members that can
help you build the tools and the
infrastructure required in your setting
to be able to integrate this into
practice and the very first step is
knowing what you don't know because
there are multiple entry points to find
the resources and in the next 30 minutes
or so I hope to provide you with some of
the beginning steps of options to
explore so let me begin with this
statement and ask you in terms of our
understanding of genetic and genomic and
integrated it into practice are we all
the same well if you look at the
literature and the research that has
been done on this topic pretty much
we're all the same health care providers
regardless of our discipline or roll
have reported similar knowledge deficits
because most of us did not have to medic
in genomic information in our academic
preparation but we do have access to
resources and those who know more so
it's a really very much a beginning step
for beginning that lifelong journey to
learn more so let me ask you this
question which health care discipline
currently has recommendations for
genetic and genomic competencies think
about your own role that you play do you
know if your discipline whether you're a
genetic counselor that's kind of a
no-brainer a nurse or advanced practice
nurse the physician or a physician
assistant do you know if you currently
have recommendations for competency or
all the above I'll give you a few
seconds to think about that and to reply
and we'll see what the knowledge level
is of knowing about your competencies
so the polls now been closed and we'll
see what the results are so obviously
many of you know that the genetic
counselors have their specialty
competencies for their scope of practice
a few of you know that nurses and
advanced practice nurses and physicians
and physicians assistants may have
competencies and almost half of you know
which is the correct answer that all the
above actually do have competencies that
can be referred to to look at what the
focus of learning may need to be so
let's go to the next step and I'll tell
you a little bit more about what the
competencies are I just have to find my
correct slide okay as many of you noted
primary care providers do have
recommended competencies and
additionally one other discipline is not
on the list pharmacists have also
identified genetic and genomic
competencies for their health care
provider education and you can find all
of these listed on a resource in the
toolkit called g2c2 at this specialty
link and as you may recognize these
competencies can really help develop
educational resources and academic
education curriculum but they can also
be a value to your thinking about your
own personal learning and how to address
perhaps your own genomic literacy gaps
so several of the disciplines have
actually published their competencies I
have the most recent article from the
physicians in genetics and medicine that
have published their physician
competencies that you heard from dr.
Bruce Korf earlier and he was very
instrumental in getting that group from
is CC which I'll tell you more about a
little bit to be able to identify them
as competencies on the right side the
physician assistants just to let you
know they've just recently updated their
competencies are in the process of
publishing them and the bottom level is
the nurses and graduate degree so these
are advanced practice nurses and grind
degree nurses that have also identified
their competencies so are they different
or are they the same well we all deal
with patients across the life continuum
in very different settings but all
advanced practice at nurses physicians
and physician assistants have some
common competencies that have been
identified across the healthcare team
and this isn't all of them obviously but
it is kind of a sampling of what you
might want to consider as you begin
targeting where to begin your own
learning you've probably heard a lot
about some of these issues today basic
genetic and genomic concepts family
history genetic and genomic testing
treatment referrals and ethical legal
social issues so I'll try to share with
you some resource resources for each of
those as we continue the conversation so
I don't know how many of you have
actually looked at all the materials
that are available from this genetics in
your clinic webinar but if you look at
the directory there is a link to the
toolkit and this great thing about now
that you're interested in this topic is
that there are tremendous number of
resources that are available for you and
your patients that have been created and
are now available sometimes the
difficulty is actually whittling down
what is the most important one to focus
on right now and when to come back to
that other resource or be able to
identify things that your patients might
be able to benefit from and so this is a
starting point and dr. Wilden and I
looked at a number of resources and
identified these that we hope will be a
value to you in your journey of learning
you can also note that from the webinar
site you can download the PDF of the
toolkit so let me begin showing you how
that toolkit is organized and how you be
able to learn a little bit more first
out the toolkit is laid out so that
there is a subject at the top and we've
identified some categories that I'll
share with you in a moment
that if you're interested in say test
interpretation or patient advocacy you
can look at the color coded version of
the category and identify the few
resources that have been added for that
specific topic next to it is the
resource itself the title the link and
these are direct links so if you're in
the PDF form on your computer you can
actually click on those and go to them
and then on the right side is a small
descriptor of the resource itself so the
categories you don't have to remember
these but you'll maybe just want to kind
of highlight in your mind if there are
certain learning areas that you want to
make sure you focus on there's some on
variant interpretation some on public
health genetic testing educational
resources of value to healthcare
providers educational webinars disease
specific information problem solving for
patients patient advocacy there are some
discipline specific specific
organizations so that you can learn more
from others that have that specialty
knowledge base and genetic and genomic
disease as well as genetic and genomic
education for the public so let me
provide you with an example of how some
of these resources might be a value to
you so Joan is being seen by you in your
office she brings up in conversation
that she's been looking into her
family's ancestry is considering sending
saliva in for genetic testing she is
excited because the company offering the
testing also provides information about
health risks and she asked your opinion
about the value of knowing such
information for her care patients are
paying attention to the ads on TVs and
in magazines and perhaps someone has
actually asked you about how to direct
their thoughts about consumer testing
and there are several resources
identified in this toolkit that provide
basic genetic and genomic information
that may be useful in answering their
questions so for example the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention has a
wonderful website that talks about
information on genomic discoveries with
population health and
it fits and as you can see from this
slide if you go to the cdc site there
are materials about hot topics of the
day and also on the right hand side
there's information about it impact
weekly scan you can actually look at
that scan and determine if the
information is of interest to you and
click on those for more information
about that specific topic i'm a cdc site
weekly update this might be very
interested in for those of you wanting
to keep up to date on what the most
recent literature or lay language
materials are coming out and so this
weekly health impact has a lot of
information about hot topics and also
about things like Alzheimer's disease
big data deep vein thrombosis just to
name a few so you can click on that
specific information or you can request
this genomic and health impact update to
keep you up to date on what is coming
out in the lay materials and also in the
literature another source of information
for primary care providers is available
from the organization the intersociety
Coordinating Committee for practitioner
education in genetics or is CC this
group brings together medical and
clinical educators from many
professional societies and related
organizations and they represent many of
our disciplines that are on this call
today including physicians genetic
counselors nurse practitioners
pharmacists physician assistants you can
name a number of many different
disciplines in there represented here
and they also have many work groups that
are working on topics of concern to
their members and so there are annual
meetings and you can attend those often
in Bethesda Maryland so if you go to the
ilc see website you can learn more about
the members and the work groups and see
if this might be a group that you could
join and learn from or help your
healthcare disciplined also be involved
the is CC work group has created a
webinar so this is located on the
webinar section of the toolkit but I
want to highlight
because I know many of you are concerned
about reimbursement issues and so the is
CC work group created this resource to
fill gap in the knowledge for insurance
companies and so you can see more about
that webinar at is CC as well so
obviously these resources are not only
in the United States there are many
international resources of great value
to each of you including the educational
resource created for the UK national
health service providers and this site
offers online course materials workshops
and a wide array of educational
resources provided to health care
service workers in the UK to utilize
genetic and genomic tools in practice so
this site may also be a great interest
to those of you or thinking about
learning more about integrating genomics
into your practice one of the challenge
is being able to find materials of value
to healthcare faculty at the beginning
of looking for resources that were out
there for teaching about genetics and
genomics information that may have
implications for practice was of the
development of a foundational site for
faculty members that provided links not
only to resources but also then try to
identify what those resources might be
able to teach to in terms of competency
concerns and recommendations so g2c2 or
the genetic genomics competency Center
has the availability of peer-reviewed
resources for use in your classroom or
practice including websites books
articles and more so i encourage you to
browse or search this site and this is
also the site where the link for the
competency documents are housed as well
now you can search this site many
different ways actually but one of the
ways is by looking for your specific
discipline so for example if you wanted
to search my position you would type in
that under the site identification for
which discipline you're looking for and
it will pull up a listing of resources
that are identified by that category of
healthcare provider and then you would
be able to see oh I can link on this
this this and this and one of those
examples is a site that is also included
in the toolkit that came from g2c2
listing of physician resources called
genetics education candidate knowledge
organization or get-go this Canadian
site has resource tools for primary care
providers and include educational
resources modules and evidence-based
summaries and it also provides listing
of public resources and genetic centers
in Canadian area so this might be a
great interest to those in Canada one of
the other things that was identified is
that as genetic and genomic information
begun begins to be implemented in
practice that it is sometimes hard to
teach those in academic settings because
you don't want to do the wrong thing or
you don't want to have perhaps you don't
have enough access to cases that are
adequately preparing the student for
what is coming for the future and so
this site called global genetics
genomics community orgy 3c was created
to help provide that interaction that
perhaps may occur with your patients in
a safe environment and be able to learn
more about the questions and concerns of
patients who perhaps beginning to
utilize this information in their
decision making so this g3 see I'm web
has 15 interdisciplinary cases as you
can see on the left side you will need
to register because cm ence is coming
available soon but we don't keep that
specific information online or anywhere
that it is held against you but it would
be possible for you to access the CEO
materials at a later point in time but
these interdisciplinary cases have case
content or notes here and then you can
click on one and have options for
learning it also has the capability of
unfolding case scenarios so that you
interview
patients at your own pace and there are
supplemental activities that can help
you learn more such as going out to look
for a screening recommendation or for
testing information it also allows you
to assess your genomic competency
because it allows you to make
recommendations and see if you made the
correct recommendation based on
resources and consider an expert
commentary on several the cases have
been added as well so there is some
spanish translation of these cases in
process and probably within the next
month or so a couple of those cases will
have that content so one of the cases
that has been identified as an
interdisciplinary case and I know you
heard about cystic fibrosis earlier
today is Lisa and she is concerned about
her potential risk because her brother
has cystic fibrosis because she's just
learned out that you learned that she's
pregnant and so she is concerned about
that issue for her family and her family
decision making so one of the other
major categories that I'm sure you have
needs as well as finding out about
genetic testing where is genetic testing
occurring what kind of genetic tests are
available whether the laboratories and
so there have been a couple of those
identified resources where you can find
out more about genetic testing and these
include two sites here that are listed
the genetic test registry or GTR and
gene test both of these provide you
information about genetic tests and
where to find labs performing them you
can filter options and links to related
information sources including on the GTR
information from some of the the
companies who are offering the testing
and the tested lab information on GTR is
voluntarily provided by the labs
themselves this site also may include
the test purpose methodology validity
evidence of the test usefulness and
laboratory contacts and credentials
on gene test you can also also filter
information and links to remake related
information sources and search for gene
disorder type of test and laboratory
location and there's also additional
links to clinical genetics resources for
practitioners so you can learn more
about information that might be of value
to you too important curated resources
and I think you also heard about this
earlier today as well that are available
to learn about the jeans and the
evidence and clinical applicability and
test interpretation are clin gin and
clinvar clin gen helps you find
resources for specific disorders you can
enter the gene the condition or the
medication to search the clinton linked
resources it also includes a button to
go to clinvar where a specific variant
search is a possibility and you can
identify where clinical laboratories
assert the clinical significance of the
individual variants that they have
assessed clin gem actually rates the
variations by evidence level and there
are webinar tutorials that can walk you
through how to best utilize this site
for your knowledge and learning and
interpretation one additional item is
available to your patients on this site
is a portal called genome connect and
this is a beginning resource for
patients be able to indicate their gene
and phenotype for registry efforts for
future research importance so let me
move on to another case pharmacogenomic
testing come is complaining of diabetic
neuropathy and you're considering
ordering carb amazeen but recognizes
Chinese anissa team a increases risk for
toxicity which it may be seen as a
severe and deadly or life-threatening
skin rash you look at this toolkit to
see if there are any resources to learn
more about recommendations for
pharmacogenomic testing and find the
clinical pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium or see pics site by
form gkb unsee pic there is some wealth
of information that is available about
certain drugs and those that have gene
tests that are available to be able to
identify whether or not they may benefit
the patient by having a different drug
or benefit the patient by having a
different dose depending on their gene
variation identified so there's
guideline information and
recommendations on peer-reviewed dosage
and gene testing guidelines for
pharmacogenomics drug gene pairs that is
very very helpful as you begin to think
about whether or not a test is available
and if so how you might go about getting
that testing done so this is the next
poll question for you I realize you may
not have seen all the resources in the
toolkit but one of the ones you've just
heard about if you have utilized one of
these toolkit resources and recommend it
to others if you could respond the
genetic testing registry or GTR the
genetic and genomic competency center or
g2c2 clin gem and or clean clinvar
global genetic genomics community orgy
3c or finally the clinical
pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium guidelines for see pic please
respond if you have used those and would
recommend them to others
whole has been closed so it looks like
the majority of you have already
utilized Clinton and our clinvar which
is very exciting to see is it is a new
resource that is being created for
clinical applications and so I think if
you haven't visited for recently you may
be surprised at its new look and feel so
I encourage you to go to Clinton include
war it looks like many of you have used
GTR as well several of you have begun to
hear about see pic guidelines and fewer
reviews of g2c2 orgy 3c so if you from
what I said or from the descriptors on
the toolkit think they might be of
interest to you I encourage you to go
and look at those resources so next I
have mentioned that there were some
educational webinars and these were a
few that we selected that might be of
value to the primary care provider and
I'm going to highlight one of the
webinars are a valuable way for
healthcare providers to think about
genomics and medicine and to identify
perhaps topics of interest to you to
guide the selection which ones you look
at the genetics and primary care
institute a collaborative project and
the american academy of pediatrics and
the maternal and child health bureau of
health resources and services
administration created a number of
resources that may be of interest to the
primary care provider only one of these
is the six-part webinar series video and
slide sets there's a lot of things that
you could view on this site the webinars
have focused on providing primary care
providers with knowledge and resources
to better provide genetic medicine as
part of a medical home and there are
long educational webinars they build on
existing primary care provider skills
and they provide a comprehensive
approach to considering how primary care
integration of genetic thinking can
occur when
every patient encounter and one of them
I'd like to highlight is this example on
the right of integrating genetics into
your practice what every primary care
provider needs to know is a webinar that
might be a value in follow-up to what
you've been already hearing today as I
mentioned earlier on these topics of the
toolkit are organized by subject so for
instance in instance excuse me if you're
interested in disease specific
information say you're an oncologist and
you're reviewing a case that you want to
know if there's any specific guidelines
related to cancer genetics there's a
wonderful resource and that may be
applicable and learning more about your
answer to what Shirley is asking you
surely receive targeted treatment of her
metastatic breast cancer she's completed
treatment is now being seen by you for
sinus infection she mentions that at her
support group one of the participants
mentioned she has the same kind of
cancer but had gotten another drug and
she's asking you if you can explain why
so one of the resources that might help
you with this disease specific
information question is a site from the
national cancer institute called pdq and
pdq provides information summaries on
genetics that are great interest I think
to those of you providing care to
patients who have a history or diagnosed
recently with cancer and for example
this is one of the cancer summaries they
provide an executive summary and then on
the right side there's a list of all
kinds of specific details about what the
evidence shows in terms of diagnosis
treatment recommendations and they also
do have information of information for
families that might know about special
referrals or care so for example on PDQ
there's an overview about cancer
genetics there's information about
cancer risk assessment and counseling
there's genetics of rest and
gynecological cancers as illustrated on
the screen genetics of colorectal cancer
genetics
endocrine and neuro endocrine neoplasia
genetics of kidney genetics of prostate
cancer and genetics of skin cancer so
you can see that this information might
be of value to you but also to the
public or patient the jurors seen so
obviously there are also a lot of
patients specific questions that come up
about rare or genetic diseases or
diseases that don't have diagnosis yet
that a patient may be coming to you and
having numerous symptoms so these sites
are value internationally because they
provide content in several languages the
genetics and rare disease site or guard
is very valuable and identifying several
ways that you can look for a disease
specialist or for someone who has
expertise and caring for a person with a
rare disorder or has experience with
that particular condition the guard site
also provides information about how to
find genetics clinics and research on a
particular condition and the guard site
has a really nice way of being able to
type in or email in or calling questions
and they will turn around responses to
the health care provider or the patient
who is asking that specific information
when a diagnosis has not yet been made
knowing about an nih-funded network of
qualified clinical centers and technical
laboratory support centers across the
u.s. where you can refer patients may be
helpful to you the undiagnosed disease
network or udn accepts applications from
patients or providers to diagnose both
rare and new diseases considered
undiagnosed through intensive clinical
and genomic research this may be a
potential solution for those confusing
patients that you want to be able to
contribute to their care but also to
contribute to discovery about genetic
and genomic contributions to health and
disease simultaneously
so this is another example of a
competency that is recommended across
the healthcare providers and referral so
as you review Kevin's family history you
note an extensive frequency of cancers
occurring a young ages this is
indicative of reddit airy syndrome in
his family and so you want to refer
Kevin took genetic specialist for
education and counseling about genetic
testing you receive the positive test
results that kevin receives after going
through genetic counseling and testing
and recognize that he needs a referral
for colonoscopy although only 30 years
old NS GC is one of the professional
member organizations that's listed in
the toolkit that offers information
about medical genetics specialty
providers and you can find policy and
practice guidelines to about the genetic
counselors and their educational
resources but one of the resources that
is of great value to you would be the
identification of clinical genetic
services and counselors perhaps locally
in your environment one of the final
common competencies that healthcare
providers and patients express concerns
about the most is knowing more about the
ethical legal social implications
associated with genetic testing so in
this case Stacey sister Peggy is
enrolled in a whole genome sequencing
study designed to determine why she
experienced cardiovascular problems at a
young age and she asked you for guidance
about participating as her sister has
requested she is concerned about use of
this information against her in the
workplace but you know about Gina so you
can discuss privacy concerns an example
of the concern about genetic information
being used against you is identified
with on this site where they provide an
overview of the federal genetic
information non-discrimination Act and
its protections in health insurance and
employment this site includes answers to
common questions about we commonly refer
to as Gina and examples to help you
learn more it was created by coalition
of policy education and advocacy groups
and although slightly older 2010 was
when the site was created the
information is well presented and
probably still very accurate and
applicable to your learning needs so
patient tools are also really important
because they often have questions about
integrating genomic information
decision-making into their care as well
and a valuable resource for patients is
the genetic Alliance a network of more
than 1,200 disease-specific advocacy
organizations for universities and
private companies government agencies
and public policy organizations this is
a very active group where they offer
shared resources and creative tools and
innovative programs at the intersection
of Health and genetics and the genetic
Alliance has also been active in policy
and general advocacy circles and so
those with genetic and rare diseases as
well as the more common diseases are
finding the genetic alliance site very
useful for learning and so may it be a
value to both you and your patients one
of the resources the genetic alliance
staff has created is called baby's first
step and this resource is a information
that prepares patients for the newborn
screening process and it offers genetic
information and family resources about
newborn screening at this local state
and national levels and it also serves
as a clearinghouse for newborn screening
information so if you're getting
questions from your patients about you
know why did my daughter-in-law and my
grandson have to go through genetic
testing differently in one state versus
another state or is that indeed true or
is that a myth and so does newborn
screening site can tell you more about
what the recommended genetic screening
is currently for newborns there are
additional patient tools many of these
are available in more than one language
and so may be a value to you if you
speak differently than English so for
example Spanish and others are available
on orphanet this is a site that provides
information on
rare disease and orphan drugs and is
designed for all audiences with links to
additional resources so this is an
official site of the european union and
they have many different languages so i
encourage you to look at that site to
learn more one other tool that is
available in English Spanish and other
languages is the family history tool
that is available from the Surgeon
General family history and the genomic
healthcare branch this site is available
english spanish as i mentioned and it's
available for family history collection
a web-based tool that helps you organize
family history and then print it out for
presentation to their health care
provider but it also can be shared with
other family members so it's a
consumer-friendly tool that will
possibly help them learn more about
sharing family information with other
members and others in their care
provider decisions I'm sure many of you
your family members as well as those
patients or their family members have
come to you and say I just don't
understand what this genomic information
is all about or do I need to understand
it and so the there's been a public
education effort through the smithsonian
museum exhibit that was in downtown DC
for several years one year excuse me
that is now coming across as a traveling
exhibit too many states and so i
encourage you to go to this companion
website to the popular Smithsonian nhgri
science exhibit and explore online it
has a virtual visit so you can see
what's included in the DNA exhibit there
are resources for teachers and students
so those kind of things may be helpful
to the general public that you can
encounter that have questions there are
topics on genomic medicine cancer
genomics and much more and so if you go
to this site you may see if that
traveling exhibit is coming to you in
the near future so if you go to the next
question this is the last question for
my section
so if you had to identify in addition to
my own education there are other steps
to integrating genetics into the clinic
I think the most important one I can
provide my leadership skills to is
evidence development guideline
development clinical infrastructure
tools such as the EHR or consideration
of reimbursement for services as you are
identified in the very first question
many of you have attended today's
workshop because you were interested in
being a leader and being able to make a
difference for patient care that is so
exciting because education is only the
first step in that and they're all these
other components are equally if not more
important in being able to make a
difference to what we can offer to
patients and their families so I'm
interested to see how many of you have
interest in leadership in one or more of
these areas
so the poll has now closed it's very
exciting to see many of you interested
in evidence development and guideline
development because that seems to be a
huge gap in helping move the translation
of genomic information into clinical
care obviously we want to make the
decisions that are best for our patients
and being able to have that evidence to
develop the guidelines is really quite
important also the clinical
infrastructure may be slightly different
from what we're used to or we may not
even know that some of our genetic
specialists are available to us in our
clinical environment and even just
setting up a referral process may be
part of that infrastructure that can be
started right away but definitely the
clinical infrastructure building on the
education and knowledge of yours
workforce and yourself will be very very
important for the future implications
and integration of this into practice
tools such as the h are going to be
quite valuable in documenting what is
learned in those genetic testing and
contributing to the decision-making
about what to do with that information
who to share it with how private can it
be how important is it to share all
those policies are yet to be refined and
so those in addition to the
reimbursement for services the smaller
number of you perhaps thinking you can
have implicit have it have the ability
to make it change there but that's still
very much a leadership role and very
much needed for what needs to happen for
the future so thanks to all of you for
thinking about those leadership roles as
you've gone through the day so let me go
to my summary slide and then we'll close
off with questions and answers for
discussion so obviously I've only
provided a sampling of what the toolkit
has to offer you the possibilities of
genomic health care are simultaneously
exciting and a bit disconcerting at the
same time for many people and so as you
begin to think about what you need to
learn and how to begin that process and
where to start download the toolkit PDF
from the ASHG site and explore some of
these resources that might
the identified is most helpful to you as
we've talked today you may be thinking
about what leadership role that you can
have to make sure this information is
integrated into care appropriately
safely and effectively as we identify
there are lots of opportunities
including interprofessional education
thinking about cost coverage evidence
development guideline creation clinical
infrastructure and tools and each of you
have begun the step in making that
difference by learning as much as you
can today and being able to help others
find these resources and be able to
reach out to make a difference for your
patients today and for the future thank
you thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can there's a
question from one of our attendees are
there reviews available of outcome
studies using current commercially
available genetic panels
you
so I know that in discussing the clinvar
and clean gen resource yesterday with
dr. Ramos and Annie they had discussed
the fact that they are encouraging those
who have are using expert panels to be
able to submit evidence of how valuable
these panels may be to identify what
tests are our value to patients so I
don't know that that is up and running
just yet dr. Bob Wilden was also
possibly going to join the question
answer and so I may defer to him if he's
available but I would encourage you to
look at clinvar and clin gym and see if
that might be a possibility to explore
further there i would like to once again
thank dr. Jenkins for her presentation
do you have any final comments for us
today now I'm just excited that so many
of you are interested in this topic and
I will be available in the lounge for 30
minutes following this session if you
want to ask more specific information
about the resource tools or anything
else I can assist you with but go forth
I know you're probably very tired after
a lot of great materials today and i
encourage you to begin this lifelong
journey or continue this lifelong
journey if you've already been involved
with genetic and genomic information for
a while and begin to help others think
about how they can come along with you
in this exciting time for patient care
thank you I have another question for
you if you have a moment which resources
do we look do we use to look up
frequency of a variant conservation etc
and what information do we need to input
about the variant in order to access
information
that's very specific information I know
that the genetic testing registry and
gene tests have links to many other
resources from their site if that
specific detail is not identified
directly underneath of what the
laboratories or others have submitted I
would encourage you you things like Oh
men or other test sites that have very
specific information have that available
as well and I know that many of the
laboratories themselves are beginning to
synthesize a lot of that materials in
the test report when it's sent back and
I will also ask if there are others who
have guidance into that did you like to
share if you'd be part of the lounge a
little bit later and type that into the
chat room we can include that in the
summary of the session today another
question for you um is there any website
specifically for ongoing trials for
genetic conditions that's a really good
question i know that clinical trials.gov
summarizes um many of the clinical
studies that are available across the
u.s. for various disease specific issues
so for instance if you go to clinical
trials gov and type in Lynch cancer
syndrome it will pop up with a number of
filters that you can apply and perhaps
find out if there are clinical trials
and you can filter by location or by the
drug or by different things so I know
that there are some genetics clinical
trials listed there I know there are
some clinical studies available through
the clinical Center at the NIH and there
is access off of the clinical Center
website to be able to find out what
clinical trials are available and again
if there are others of you know of
resources please type that in and let us
know
thanks again this is an educational
virtual meeting and now software's free
continuing education credits after the
session is over please click on the c/e
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits
today's virtual meeting will be
available for on-demand viewing through
September 22nd 2016 you will receive an
email from lab roots alerting you in
this session will be available for
replay and we invite you to afford that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event you were
also invited to join dr. Jenkins in a
networking round shortly after her talk
concludes where she will be answering
questions for 30 minutes just go to the
meeting lobby and enter the networking
lounge in the lounge there's a live chat
feature where you can type in your
questions if you asked a question in
this session it will not transfer to the
lounge so you will have to re-enter your
query see you next time goodbye